a rapper actors in a Broadway star for
one reason or another parted ways from
their jobs for refusing to get
vaccinated
in November of 2021 General Hospital
fans were shocked to discover longtime
star Steve Burton who portrayed Jason
Morgan on the drama for 30 years had
been fired from the series following his
refusal to get the covid-19 vaccine the
actor said as much via an Instagram post
in which he stated hey I wanted you to
hear it from me I love and appreciate
all of you unfortunately General
Hospital has let me go because of the
vaccine mandate I did apply for my
medical and religious exemptions and
both of those were denied which you know
hurts per deadline Burton tested
positive for covid-19 in August but he
explained how his decision not to get
the vaccine came down to personal
freedom I don't think anybody should
lose their livelihood over this Burton
doesn't rule out a return to General
Hospital although his character was
presumably killed off in an episode that
aired shortly before his Instagram
comments
as it turns out Steve Burton wasn't the
only General Hospital star who refused
the covid-19 vaccine fellow actor Ingo
Rademacher who would start as Jasper JAX
on the series since 1996. likewise
attempted to file a religious exemption
and was quickly denied and fired from
the show Rolling Stone published the
actor's exemption letter on December 13
2021 it reads I am entitled to a
religious exemption against mandatory
vaccination for covid-19 on the basis of
my moral belief that my body is endowed
by my creator with natural processes to
protect me and that cannot ethically be
violated by the administration of
artificially created copies of genetic
material foreign to Nature and
experimental the sudden turn of events
open the door for even more drama when
radamacher filed a lawsuit against ABC
as he felt the covid-19 protocols were a
direct violation of his civil rights he
stated there is no need for everybody to
get the covid-19 shot even if the
president demand Transit the case goes
to court in February 2023 according to
Radar Online
following Ingo rademacher's lead 911
star Rockman Dunbar likewise filed a
lawsuit against Disney and 20th
television for refusing to honor his
request for a religious exemption
regarding the vaccine
and I said to myself
I can do that too after portraying
Michael Grant for 69 episodes the actor
had his contract terminated in November
2021 that followed his refusal to comply
with Studio mandates an action he felt
was discriminatory as such he attempted
to navigate the situation via religious
exemption to no avail leading Dunbar to
sue in February 2022 the actor said in a
statement to deadline I applied for
religious and medical accommodations
pursuant to the law and unfortunately
was denied by my employer my sincerely
held beliefs in private medical history
are very intimate and personal aspects
of my life that I do not publicly
discuss and have no desire to start now
despite the controversy Dunbar is
scheduled to appear in upcoming
Productions red winter and the Waterboys
another name that popped up in the wake
of the covid-19 vaccine controversy was
Andrea Bordeaux she revealed on
Instagram that she was fired from the
star's lion gate TV series run the world
after failing to follow onset guidelines
in the post she discussed how much fun
she had working on the production
calling the experience a dream come true
and saying that she had no desire to
exit the series Bordeaux wrote in
response to a report posted by deadline
despite what the article says I did not
opt to leave the series and Lionsgate
made no efforts to find a workable
solution I was fired Bordeaux appeared
in all eight episodes of season one of
Run the World As Ella she also had
appeared in TV shows such as NCIS Los
Angeles Criminal Minds and Law and Order
Special Victims Unit according to her
IMDb profile the actor is not slated to
appear in any upcoming Productions
Ice Cube wasn't fired from the
production of the comedy oh hell no
which was set to shoot in Winter 2021
but he exited the film after turning
down the covid-19 vaccine according to
the Hollywood Reporter
as a result of his exit Ice Cube lost
out on a 9 million dollar payday
if he had stayed on the movie would have
paired him alongside the great Jack
Black and Netflix's bad trip director
kitau Sakurai
even still the popular rapper actor was
a vocal supporter of mask wearing and
even helped support the cause by selling
T-shirts and Scribe with a phrase check
yourself before you wreck yourself Ice
Cube also ended up departing a Universal
Pictures project called Flint strong
which actually filmed for one day before
production was put on a Hiatus in March
2020 as the spread of covet began to
accelerate it's not clear why he left
that film which is said to be looking
for a new star and possibly Studio
as of now no one has been tapped to
replace Ice Cube in oh hell no though
Jack Black is currently still aboard
Broadway star Laura ostness made waves
when the New York Post reported that she
had been fired from a one night only
production of crazy for you for not
getting the covid-19 shot however the
actor later sued the post for defamation
according to Forbes claiming she did not
get fired from the show but rather quit
on her own terms austinus was hesitant
to get the vaccine and ultimately
decided to withdraw from the production
after learning it would require proof of
vaccination
she wrote in a statement I would have
tested in a heartbeat something I had
been doing for months and will continue
to do so in order to keep working safely
the actor then added I believe
individuals have the right to do
research consult a doctor and come to
their own conclusions before deciding
whether or not to get any injection